qui est élu mais on la joue pas à
bouillon en 1995 ce qui veut dire en
quelques pages en est pour 4 mandature
22,6 année après ses études au conseil
général donc
là aussi ben là j'ai pu accumuler
certaines compétences avoir
effectivement comment est ce que les
institutions fonctionnent après ça a été
la présidence de l'association des
maires et puis bombes et des
réalisations qu'ils avaient à faire sur
notre collectivité j'ai un cheval de
bataille qui est ma petite enfance et la
cellule familiale mais il n'ya pas que
ça lorsque ben bella les cieux il y a
déjà pas mal de projets il y a les
problèmes de l'environnement il y a les
dotations qui ne sont pas servir
convenablement au départ autrement et
aux départements d'outre-mer et puis
naturellement à certains secteurs qui
ont qui sont en souffrance l'agriculture
la pêche
donc tout ça il y a vraiment du travail
à mener là dessus que je suis celui-là
la ligne de départ comme les autres que
affaires à faire campagne de commune en
commune jusqu à ce qu effectivement on
est ce résultat du 24 savoir
effectivement qui deux morts lequel tu
ne seras ses nageurs à montcenis